[music]
Announcer: "We have cleared the tower.
The Cassini spacecraft is on its way to Saturn."
Barber: "Cassini is nearly out of propellant.
We have 1 percent of the propellant left,
plus or minus 2 percent.
We can’t risk Cassini becoming a piece of space junk
around Saturn that could end up crashing into
one of a few Saturn moons that apparently
have liquid water environments,
just a perfect breeding ground for life.
So we cannot risk contaminating those moons
with earthbound bacterial spores.
We have to preserve those worlds for future exploration.
On September 11, 2017,
we’ll do about a 120,000 kilometer flyby of Titan.
That’s close enough that Titan’s gravity
is going to nudge us,
and that nudge will lower our closest approach to Saturn
to a point that’s within Saturn’s atmosphere.
So from that point forward,
we only have about half of an orbit.
The very last full day of the mission, which is the 14th,
rather than focus on one target or another,
we’re giving every scientific discipline
a chance to say goodbye.
So we have the last Titan picture,
the last Enceladus picture…
If you’re moving out of a house
you’ve been in for decades,
you might want to take one last walk
through the house and say goodbye to each room
and the memories you had in those rooms,
so that’s what we’re doing."
[music]
"So, by the morning of September 15,
we’ll reconfigure the spacecraft to actually become
a real-time data collector and sender,
a task for which it was never designed.
About 1:37 a.m. Pacific Daylight Time,
we’ll begin a five-minute roll.
We’ll roll the spacecraft to put INMS,
the Ion and Neutral Mass Spectrometer,
in a good direction to sniff the atmosphere of Saturn.
A little over three hours later,
we’ll enter the atmosphere,
and the thrusters will start firing
to counter balance the torque from the atmosphere.
And this is the key moment where we’re
sniffing Saturn’s upper atmosphere for the first time.
The amazing thing is that
out of our twelve science instruments onboard, eight,
everything but the cameras basically, are taking data.
And we hope to take data literally up to the last second.
But at some point the atmosphere wins
and the thrusters even firing 100% of the time
can’t overcome that torque.
So the spacecraft will essentially
point away from the Earth
And at that point we can’t maintain high gain data
and get a signal.
From when we first start measuring the atmosphere
until we no longer communicate with the spacecraft,
that’s essentially one to two minutes.
In a way, maybe it’s better that
we don’t see what happens next.
We’re screaming in at 76,000 miles per hour.
The fact that we’re going so fast makes
a lot of atmospheric friction and heat.
And that heat is what melts
and then vaporizes the spacecraft.
Essentially, there are different parts of the spacecraft
that have different melting points.
The thermal blankets will burn off first
and then aluminum will start to melt.
All those molecules from our earthbound emissary
are then part, permanently, of Saturn’s atmosphere,
a real ashes to ashes and dust to dust story for Cassini.
[music]